I'm here with little ethnic village
Corey and I thought it'd be interesting
since we're in Bloomberg west to talk
about the high-tech I karzai line that
they have at Ludwig is a race car driver
and a car collector but you happen to
drive the i3 when you told me that in
Detroit I I couldn't believe it but you
said it's really got the BMW DNA in it
absolutely and that's why I Drive it
really I mean the way it drives that
it's so agile it's light it's great as
far as acceleration is concerned that's
all you need for commute so this is what
the car is meant for it it is i bmw true
to its brand so the i3 is an
all-electric car you can get it with a
range extender but that doesn't drive
the axle it's completely green in that
sense it is and it's all any green in
the sense that it's emission-free what
we think is also very important that the
whole production is very sustainable we
start producing the carbon fiber and
Moses Lake Washington with hydropower ie
we just use water to produce it we don't
have any electricity outside of our own
plan necessary then the cars build in
Leipzig Germany with wind power so the
whole production cycle we also you lose
use about half of the water you will use
otherwise so the production is much more
sustainable it's much more emission-free
than anybody else can produce a car
which we think is as far as the carbon
footprint distance are really important
if you talk about sustainability of an
automobile so I have yet to drive the i3
myself I have had the pleasure of
driving the i8 and it is shockingly it's
amazing you don't expect it to be as
good as is the grip is incredible the
way it lays down power is so smooth and
linear and this is a concept that I
think your competitors are finally
catching on to the fact that you can
have this hybrid green powertrain and
still have so much power I mean it's
almost like you feel whatever the
opposite of green is but you're but
you're still doing something good for
the environment absolutely it's the best
of two worlds it's the stunning looks of
the supercar
it's a performance of the supercar you
can even sit for people at least on a
shorter journey and you have more than
70 miles to the gallon I mean this is
something that hasn't been accomplished
by anybody else and again it's the the
sustainable production method that
really makes the car stick out it's far
as assistant the sustainability is
concerned what do you think is the
future of BMW powertrains I mean in your
regular in the 3 Series in the 5 Series
in the seventh series are we good are we
going to eventually see electric power
alongside gasoline and diesel engines we
will we will have plug-in hybrids for
all the major models and that's the
future we think that you be able to do
both you drive electrically in the city
but use the conventional drive train for
the freeways what about the future
connectivity i mean i think the eye dr
is the best system as far as
infotainment systems but this in car
tech is getting to be more and more
important especially in Silicon Valley
obviously where's BMW headed with that
well very clearly and that's not only in
Silicon Valley people are interested in
getting more connectivity to get
information at their fingertips that
they want to have while they're driving
but it's also about having some little
helpers like self parking whenever it's
not so much fun to drive a BMW
electronics kick in and help you that's
what it's all I mean I think of it
obviously the ultimate driving machine
is the slogan I grew up with and when I
get behind the wheel of a BMW I want to
drive myself but are we going to see a
day when there's an autonomous BMW maybe
if you're really in a bad traffic
situation you will be able to engage a
ton of its driving because it's no fun
you can lend you you males or you read a
book or whatever you want but as soon as
you want to drive again you decide
yourself it should always support the
driver but don't dominate the drive I
want to finally ask about the
motorcycles you got the new S 1000
behind you I'm
fan of two wheels how does this
integrate into the cars that you're
producing well obviously we started the
building motorbikes a long time before
we started with cars so this is part of
our heritage it's part of our DNA it's
part of our brand so it fits perfectly
to the ultimate ultimate driving machine
it's part of BMW all right Ludwig thanks
so much for your time really appreciated
Ludwig village runs BMW North America